au centre commercial vélizy 2 ce
mercredi matin les vitrines des magasins
annonce la couleur
les soldes d'hiver ont commencé des
réductions de 50% dès la première
démarque
après les fêtes les premiers jours de
soldes font partie des périodes les plus
importantes pour le centre et ses 160
enseignes
toute l'équipe est prête que ce soit au
niveau de l'accueil des équipes de
nettoyage de maintenance tout le monde
est mobilisé en fait pour accueillir nos
clients dans les meilleures positions
dans les rayons on fouille on cherche et
on fait bien attention à l'étiquette
pour trouver les meilleures affaires moi
je vois pas mal sur pantalon sur les
chevilles
chacun sa méthode les plus raisonnables
se fixe tant budget je voudrais dépenses
et ne pas dépenser plus de 100 euros
mais bon ça dépend ce que je vais
trouver et les plus organisés viennent
avec une idée précise
je suis venu chercher un repérage que ma
femme avait fait le week end dernier
donc je fais des lui acheter une paire
de chaussures
les premiers jours s les plus importants
en terme d'affluence alors il fallait
être sur la ligne de départ dès ce
mercredi pour être certain de trouver
chaussure à son pied
ah oui exactement parce que pour des
chaussures après on ne trouve pas la
bonne pointure que dans cette enseigne
de prêt-à-porter quarante mille articles
sont démarqués six semaines pour
liquider les stocks et installer les
collections printemps été